in this video I want to talk about how
codons and anticodons base pair so
codons are on mRNA molecule and
anticodons are on tRNA molecules so the
mRNA with the codon is read by the tRNA
5 prime to 3 prime so the tRNA is
actually running in the opposite
direction and the base pairs that form
form in an anti parallel fashion so the
tRNA like I just mentioned contains the
anticodon it also contains an amino acid
at its 3 prime CCA end so in this
diagram here we have an mrna molecule
here and it contains the codon now
notice the mRNA is running 5 prime to 3
prime to the right the tRNA is running 5
prime to 3 prime to the left so they are
anti parallel and this tRNA here has
this as the anticodon and they base pair
so here we have you see see the
anticodon being complementary AGG so now
this amino acid is what's coded for by
this codon so if it's codon is you see
see what or which amino acid should this
be
let's check this table if we have you
see see that should be a serine so the
answer here is that this amino acid
should be serine why should it be a
serine because the mRNA said so the mRNA
codon determines what amino acid should
be attached here so now this is the tRNA
and this is the amino acid and they're
connected together when they're
connected together they form this thing
called the amino acyl tRNA I hope that
video was helpful in understanding how
the codons and anticodons base pair
one last thing I am a tutor if you live
until the kauffman you feel free to
contact me via email at move University
at gmail.com see the description below
for more details thank you for watching